we had a deal I get to be there when you
take him down I'm not going to kill him
I'm gonna make him wish he was dead
prometheus me so viola he knows that I'm
the green arrow Evelyn why this city
needs to be saved from you
hey everybody Oliver versus Prometheus
fight night going down next week so
let's break it down I also have some
news about live-action and Teen Titans
and there's a new round of the flash
ring giveaway all you have to do to
enter that flash ring giveaway is just
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video make sure you click that Bell
to enable alerts so that you don't miss
out on anything if it wasn't clear
before it is definitely clear now that
that is Worf doing the voice for
Prometheus Michael Dorn which I totally
love and he's speaking so much more now
they kind of threaded that into the
season like first we heard him say he
was prometheus it almost didn't sound
like Michael Dorn but the more he'd
speak in recent episodes like it just
absolutely confirmed it like you could
not deny yeah that definitely sounds
like Worf getting ready to crush someone
I told you to stay away from the green
arrow I don't work for you and the green
arrow found me you kidnapped his protege
so the whole theme of this trailer is
kind of the theme of the first half of
the season this is the mid-season finale
so they're closing down the setup of
Oliver being the villain
of arrow season 5 at least in the eyes
of Prometheus and now Artemis because
you basically see Prometheus here just
trying to torment him because of
something that he did in the past like
Prometheus was created because of
something that Oliver did in season 1
now we know it's because of the list it
looks like he's in some broken-down
office building so maybe this is in the
glades somewhere it just sounds like
Prometheus was related to or had a
business in the glades maybe he was tied
up in the undertaking or had family
members tied up in it that was going to
make the city better at least Merlyn in
his cabal thought that that would make
the city better but Oliver wasn't having
it and then for the next like couple
seasons we had all-out assault on the
city like things almost got worse so
even though people like Artemis only
started hating Oliver recently
Prometheus has been in training this
whole time since season 1 to do what
he's doing this season to Oliver in his
friends so I like the way they cut this
where they like splice Prometheus in
like he's secretly watching everyone
where they're walking like you see his
reflection
pop up next to Oliver you see his shadow
pop up next to Felicity's boyfriend kind
of throwing a little bit of water on the
idea that he's prometheus but when you
look at him here like hunched over this
table cleaning his weapons he has a
giant back like he looks like a huge
dude
which makes me want to cross a lot of
people off the list and I know that
Colton Haynes has like a pretty big bag
like he's pretty jacked but I don't
think he's this big he's not bigger than
Stephen Amell so even though I'm not
expecting Kovar Dolph Lundgren from the
flashbacks to be the villain a
present-day I feel like this person is
from Star City prometheus is somebody
from the city that Oliver trashed while
he was trying to save it
kovar is just one of the few people who
is big enough to fit this profile here
whoever he is he's meant to be more than
a physical match for Stephen Amell and
they're gonna have like a badass
knock-down drag-out fight it's the
mid-season finale so they saved the
biggest reveals like if you remember
Deathstroke was revealed in the
mid-season finale during season two
Rachael Ghul almost killed Oliver now he
is going to have it out with Prometheus
so like even Stephen Amell has been
posting pictures from behind the scenes
of some of the stunts that they're gonna
be doing but you young justice fans out
there will look at this Artemis
storyline hurt betraying the team and
think about sports master stuff going on
prometheus is not her father they did
explain how long she's been working with
Prometheus it has not been this whole
time they said it was around episode six
where the team found out about the list
it was like between act breaks and they
all got super pissed off and it almost
seemed like team arrow was gonna break
up that was the moment that she decided
to work with Prometheus so it hasn't
been for that long Young Justice Artemis
was the daughter of two villains
Sportsmaster and Huntress
so she rebelled by trying to be good but
they kept pulling at her trying to get
her to turn on the team so we might see
some flip-flopping from Artemis like she
wants to believe in the team she's not
completely evil she just thinks that
Oliver is evil like she says the city
needs to be saved from you big shocking
twist so there are a couple different
ways that that could go down one Oliver
could convince her that
he's trying to do the right thing and
she'll come around and rejoin the team
eventually - shall be the tragic
character that prometheus will kill just
to torment Oliver so that's one more
body on his conscience like Prometheus
says he doesn't want to kill Oliver he
just wants to torment him to prolong his
sorrow as much as possible so look at
this freaky chart here then look at mr.
terrific getting his ass handed to him
like he doesn't look like he's dead it
just looks like prometheus puts him in
the hospital and then look at the chart
again and see the big X through Quentin
so I know that makes it seem like he's
dead but it's probably just prometheus
putting him down for the count so you
see all these other people he's going
after I would not be surprised if
there's at least one major death before
the end of the season and I think that
Artemis is at the top of that list so
let me know in the comments if
Prometheus ends up killing anybody
that's on his list here like his reverse
version of the list so you think that
artemis is going to be the one to get
the shaft but even though that sounds
like a bit of a bummer it's gonna get
pretty crazy now that we're moving into
the back half of the season that moment
in the big crossover episode the arrow
100th episode from last night where
Oliver saw all those shadows saw Tommy
saw his parents saw Roy they were
reassuring him that he was a good person
doing the right thing giving him that
bump he needed to continue his mission
the path that his father set him on with
the list like it all started with the
list on the island it's just that
Oliver's methods have changed over time
not the mission the mission is the same
so what I'm expecting is is less
indecisiveness from all of her like he's
fully committed he like he knows he's
doing the right thing so he's just going
to hard-charge Prometheus and throw down
big time so if you or your friends
haven't been watching arrow this season
now is the time to jump back on because
we're doing Talia al Ghul in the back
half of the season and Laurel is coming
back with some big twist I have no idea
what its gonna look like they've only
said that Laurel is coming back she's
alive and well they didn't say what the
twist is or what
that's gonna look like or what the
dynamic with the group is gonna be or if
she's gonna be doing black Canary's
stuff in Artemus dying I know that would
be a bummer for live-action Teen Titans
potential but just to talk about that so
Andrew Kreisberg one of the big
producers in this arrow universe he's
mostly working on Supergirl but he also
created the flash TV show he kind of
runs both shows he is like a lifelong
hardcore Teen Titans fan like when
people ask him what his favorite title
is it's always Teen Titans so the fact
that they have most of the Teen Titans
or even Young Justice cast means that
they'll probably try to develop
something like that in the future
they're all about the big team ups now
they get double the ratings when they do
stuff like this so it makes sense they
try to do something like that when arrow
eventually goes off the air but let me
know you guys want live-action Teen
Titans they have the Hall of Justice now
so they have to do Teen Titans at some
point and for those of you that keep
asking about the TNT live-action Teen
Titans they were originally developing a
Titan show that died last year so it's
no longer in development at TNT the
people that were working on that aren't
working on it anymore
meaning that it's free for other people
to turn into a show but the other really
cool thing that just happened I'll talk
about this more when we get more
information but Warner Brothers and DC
Comics is working on a digital
subscription service like HBO now just
for DC Comics movies and TV shows
they're talking about animated stuff
they're talking about the live-action
movies they're talking about stuff like
The CW TV shows but because they're just
starting to make Young Justice season 3
it's gonna take a little while to finish
what they might do is use that digital
subscription service to launch that so
at some point in the future in the next
year or two you'll be able to like
subscribe to a digital subscription
service that is just comic book stuff
and on the flip side of that Disney is
thinking about doing the exact same
thing with Marvel and Star Wars content
so I feel like a lot of people like pay
a bunch of extra money just because they
want that one channel like you just want
HBO or you just want to get the comic
book stuff eventually you'll be able to
do that without having to spend like a
ton of extra money so
next I'm gonna try and get that Rick and
Morty season 3 video out then we have
the last night of the crossover on
legends tonight so that video will post
tonight if I don't think I'm gonna get
Rick and Morty out then I'll just post
that tomorrow and there is some
spider-man homecoming stuff that's
coming tomorrow so get I i'll remind all
you guys about that when i post my
legends video later tonight while you
guys wait for that to post you can click
here for my arrow 100th episode video
and you can click here for the trailer
for next week's flash episode thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight